Hey,
what's going on is spill barn is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And
I'm just checking in on you,
checking you to sell my voices junk.
I just did six shows up in San Jose.
Hey,
I've been for the Houston Astros so it was one of my favorite players.
Yeah,
my voice is going to be a little tight.
It's gonna be a little rough,
you know.
Um,
I did six shows up there to Monday to Tuesday to Wednesday,
just like when I was in Phoenix to Monday to Tuesday to fucking Wednesday.
I'm putting together my new a hour and I really felt by Wednesday of this week
it had gotten to the point we're starting to do,
starting to take shape.
And I was very happy and I want to thank everybody who came out,
you know,
on school nights.
I know you guys all have to work unless you hit the fucking lottery.
I assumed all he had to go to work the next day.
So I want to thank everyone in San Jose who came out to go see me.
And,
um,
thank you for sitting through the new jokes.
I had a great time up there.
Worked with Dean del,
you fucking crushed it,
crushed it all fucking week.
Um,
had a great time working with them,
you know,
and dean,
like,
this is the funny thing about team when I worked with Dean Dean,
you know,
he doesn't party or anything like that.
He's done all of that shit.
So He's over it.
So then,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a fucking codependent jackass,
you know what I mean?
So I mean,
to a point,
someone's doing cocaine,
heroin,
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm going to bed.
Okay.
Um,
but it's when it comes to the booze was smoking cigars,
right.
That's why,
you know,
me and all my friends,
I mean,
we're all codependent guys and we just fucking feed off of each other and it
becomes fucking,
you know,
animal house.
But,
um,
so he,
he's,
he doesn't do that.
Right.
So my os can be great.
You know,
I'm not going to spend any extra money and no extra calories.
I was hitting the gym,
was doing everything great.
But a,
the thing about dean is he has impeccable taste in shit that I like old
instruments,
old cars.
He was showing me this guy that fucking read does these portion nine eleven's
out here that would just fucking insane,
insane.
Like he has all like,
you know,
not a lot of stuff but he has all top of the line shit.
So I was joking with them,
I was like all the money that I'm going to fucking not blowing a bar after my
show.
I'm then going to spend 10 times more that on fucking Ebay after I get done
talking to you.
But um,
anyways,
he murdered at all week.
We had such a great time in San Jose in front.
That's one of my favorite places because it's really,
it's really,
it's a small theater,
you know,
from the turn of the last century,
I believe it was built in the 1890s burned down back when shit used to burn down
all the time cause it was may not of fucking wood,
you know,
as opposed to what now bill,
I don't know.
We did,
they didn't have sprinklers.
That's what it was.
What a houses man out of plastic bill.
You know,
you've been on a Hollywood so long,
you plastic phony,
you think everything's made out of plastic.
Well then they would melt.
Right?
Plastic is it flammable?
But I could just cowers you know what I mean?
Like your friend who says,
I got your back.
I'm not going to fucking rent.
Yeah.
Then all of a sudden the teacher comes walking in and he goes,
he always his idea,
that's what plastic is.
You know,
why?
Cause it's manmade.
Um,
anyways,
so it burned down and then they rebuilt it in the early 19 hundreds and everyone
from like Harry Houdini,
Charlie Chaplin,
they always bring up those two guys.
Nobody ever says,
uh,
you know,
fatty Arbuckle played here.
Nobody gives a shit.
Right.
I love that name.
Fatty Arbuckle.
You know,
that's back when you just,
you said what the person was for better for worse.
You know what I mean?
You know,
you could just say get fatty Arbuckle.
Why?
Cause cause he's a fat fuck.
You know?
Sure.
He had a first name.
Nobody knows what it is,
but people go,
you know,
back then it was great,
you fucking,
yeah,
but then people also walk around,
drop for the fucking Edward,
you know,
like they were saying pass the sugar.
But the upside to that was you,
you knew who sought what as opposed to now where he goes,
African American,
a homosexual America,
Japanese Americans,
and you have no idea who's what.
Everybody's walking around and you feel like you're in the fucking invasion of
the body snatchers.
Who's thinking what?
Right.
Everybody's reading from the same book.
It's not good God damn thing.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about right now.
Um,
I literally got off,
got on the earliest flight.
I'm doing this thing now because I want to run home,
rush home and see my daughter,
my daughter.
But I get home cause I take the earliest flight out and I'm fucking exhausted.
Then I have to go to sleep.
So I'm
sucks.
I came home.
I think she has to remember who I am just three days away,
three days away.
Like as far as what percentage of her life she was looking at me like making
this face like who the fuck is this guy?
She didn't cry.
Thank God they would have broke my heart,
but you know,
it took me like 20 minutes to get a smile out of her.
Um,
what else am I going to do?
One at nine to five job,
you know,
drive a fucking
Chevy Cavalier.
Like what?
What the fuck a lot of you guys are doing right now.
Stuck in traffic.
I know you don't want to do that,
right?
You got to dream.
Let me tell you something.
You got to,
you got to find that dream.
You got to go after it.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
do whatever the fuck you want to do.
You know,
this is a lot of times I look at somebody sitting in a cubicle and that would be
great right there.
I just fucking sit there.
I just,
I,
I go from here to right fucking there.
Right?
I just send my chair spins from this to here.
That's my range of fucking motion.
I get my job done and I go home and you know something that this country company
goes under.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll go,
I'll just go to another one.
Ain't on me,
you know,
not rent to own rental leaf.
That's how you'd do it anyways.
Uh,
what's going on in my world?
Other than that,
I'm excited.
Finally excited about my new hour.
Finally,
finally,
after had some fucking jokes.
I'm the fucking boss,
Steve,
Bro.
And still,
they got a win tonight that playing fucking Tampa Bay lightening down there in
Florida.
Dude,
I know,
like fucking 12 people already fucking move down there.
You know what I mean?
It's fucking crazy.
It's like,
what do you fucking 80 can't take the win anymore.
You got to lose your edge stowed.
Yeah,
Dude.
I went down there.
I,
I visited fucking,
I visited fucking whatever.
Fucking Bobby McAfee
dude.
He's always walking around in shorts.
Fucking flip flops sitting down by a dog,
hanging out with all these fucking Weirdos.
Just like,
don't you know,
you look at you,
you're all fucking tanned up.
You know it's good,
but do you,
you got to come back to,
you got to go to donkeys,
get to lodge the extra sugar,
um,
bronzer and middle of the three game fucking slide.
We lost Edmonton and then we went over to Edmonton,
Alberta and then we went to Toronto,
Ontario and we fucking lost there.
And then we went to Ottawa,
the capital,
ladies and gentlemen of Canada.
I was actually,
I was trying to remember all the provinces,
the provinces and territories,
this 10 provinces and three territories up there.
And I could never fucking room room cause most of them begin with n full of old
enough of 'em do Nova Scotia,
New Brunswick.
Then there's something in Labrador retriever or some shit.
What the fuck is it?
New Brunswick,
Nova Scotia,
Newfoundland and Labrador.
Prince Edward Island.
And the rest easy.
You just go on across according to fucking hockey teams,
the Quebec Nordiques,
well Toronto may police then at the Ontario my beliefs and then at the Manitoba,
Manitoba fucking jets.
It's the Winnipeg jets,
right?
Saskatchewan,
Alberta,
British Columbia.
Then you go up top,
you've got the northwest and territory,
you got Yukon,
and then the other one like fucking,
because when an end,
it sounds like an Italian word,
but it isn't like,
forget about it.
The fuck is that thing called,
this has to be in the history of podcasting.
The most boring thing anybody's ever brought up.
Canadian.
Come on.
You can't.
I'm going to Wikipedia Canadian,
tear it door.
Uh,
terror tour territory's the fuck is it called?
It's something Italian provinces and territories of Canada.
Please take out your geography books.
The fuck is it called?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
None.
None of what?
Oh no,
that's not,
doesn't sound Italian.
Hey,
we'll have none of that.
Okay.
Knock it off.
None.
No,
none of that.
None of that would work.
Fuck off.
I got most of them.
All right.
So anyways,
the Bruins were playing Tampa Bay tonight.
We need a win,
you know,
and we just fucking beat Edmonton.
We've just won one of those fucking gays.
We had little breathing room,
a little breathing Roman.
Now we don't.
Now it's just like,
you know Joe Barton,
Dick taught me,
talked me off the ledge,
she goes,
you know they will fucking tired.
They had back to back games.
Don't fucking it the bannock panic button yet.
Then we lost again to fucking Ottawa.
Okay.
So I'm gonna listen to Joe Barton it cause he knows way more about hockey than
I'll ever fucking know.
But if they lose tonight,
yeah.
Isn't this,
we're looking at possibly three years in a row of being in the playoffs with two
weeks to go in March and then sitting at home.
You know,
which partner gets told me that's the worst fucking thing to just miss the
playoffs.
Okay.
Cause you don't get any play off money and you don't get a good draft pick.
But who knows?
Maybe somebody will miss somebody good.
I mean that's how we got Tom Brady,
right?
Everybody just fucking was looking at him like,
you know,
he's got a nice dimple in his chin.
But other than that,
I don't know.
You can see why they passed a bike and see why they passed a by when he fucking
dove after he threw that pick six,
you know,
and the Superbowl this year.
Just look that up.
Him diving to tackle and just look at how unathletic he looks.
You know,
anytime anybody ever says like fucking hot have fucked it.
All these teams way to the what?
What was he in the fourth round?
Six round.
How did they miss this guy?
Just show that video and just say,
imagine that running the 40 yard dash.
You know what Tom Brady is?
He's a fucking slave.
That's what he is.
He showed up looking like a Volvo station wagon and they didn't realize what was
under the hood.
You know what it was?
It was a four 54 454 cubic kid.
She's a fucking hat dude.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Plowing ahead.
Um,
other sports stock Formula One starts on this Sunday if you want to get into it
like I did last year and last year,
the Mercedes Benz team with Lewis Hamilton and Nico Rosberg,
this sense retired.
Nico Rosberg cause he wanted to hang out with his daughter,
which I didn't fuck over his kid,
which I didn't understand until I came home after three days in San Jose and my
own daughter's looking at me like,
uh,
is this the driver?
Who the hell's this guy?
Um,
okay.
Who knows?
Okay.
I always,
I always want to blame the woman.
You know,
that his wife was like,
it's really dangerous.
I mean,
you won the championship.
this whole thing with Louis,
it's just,
it's,
you talk about it all the time.
We can't even sit down for a meal.
I get it.
You think he's a con?
But you know,
I just,
what about us?
Did you just be here with me?
Okay.
You know,
that's the danger of being with the wrong woman.
You,
you end up stepping out of a formula one car and just say,
Hey,
you know what?
Oh,
maybe he's smart.
Maybe he's just like that guy who plays blackjack and goes up early and just
says,
Hey,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I'm going back to the room,
taking my money and I'm going back to the fucking room.
I have no idea.
I don't even understand this God damn sport to be honest with you.
I still don't what happened to the steering wheel and why it looks like a
fucking game boy now.
And how the fuck sitting there like driving that Goddamn fast.
You have time to take your hand off the wheel and fucking search for that button
to pick a new,
uh,
a new suspension.
Like you're in a Tesla with your friend driving up fucking route to,
hey,
you want me to put it in an insane fucking mode?
Whatever the hell it is,
except they're doing this shit at 200 miles an hour.
By the way,
I went by a Tesla dealership when I was up in San Jose and um,
they have,
uh,
they had the new one up there,
you know,
that had,
they had,
um,
you know,
the original one just had the motor,
um,
for the rear wheels.
Now they got one for the front and the back.
And evidently it goes,
we need to get the top of the line,
the best one,
right?
It's,
it's literally with them.
It's just like what,
what gives it,
um,
makes it worth more money is the amount of fucking electrical power you have.
It's all of it.
Cause everything other than that,
I think they're pretty much all the same.
And if you get to top of the line one,
um,
it goes zero to 60 in 2.5 seconds.
That's like a fucking,
that's motorcycles level speed.
Um,
and it's a four door,
looks like a fucking Nissan maximum.
Not even now.
It doesn't look like that.
It looks like maybe like a Toyota super fucked in Nissan Masks.
Maximum one of those late.
MMM,
late eighties once.
Um,
was it the super,
the Celica?
I can't fucking remember.
All I know is,
you know what car I would love to fucking own for like a year is one of those
like a 71 or 72,
like Datsun five,
10.
Just have the whole fucking thing redone.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you.
I,
you're,
I'm hard pressed to find a fucking car that I,
that I can't see.
That wouldn't be fun to drive.
You know what I mean?
There's so many fucking great cars out there.
The only ones I,
I,
I'm not really interested in is all the American muscle cars at this point,
because they're just fucking everywhere.
Everybody has one.
Every time you put on meek and we've got some mopar power coming up and it's the
same guy.
He comes a Kudo.
It comes a fucking hand.
This hemi that it comes to Shelby,
he comes to fucking,
you know,
the daily made a couple of these Camaro's.
There's the 19 fucking 69 you know,
this is a Mustang boss.
It's the,
they're all fighting over the same fucking three models.
Meanwhile,
there's all these other fucking coolest cars out there.
Um,
I'm actually glad that the baby boomers are still infatuate that cause it keeps
the prices down of the shit that I like.
Um,
yeah.
I'm a fucking Weirdo dude.
I like those.
Ford does Ford vans from the 60s.
You know,
it's just a shame that you know,
a couple of fucking serial killers that dressed up like clowns drove around
advanced,
they really ruined the name of them.
But what's the upside of that?
The
upside of pedophilia is if you're into vans,
you can get one for really cheap.
The trade off is you can never grow a mustache for the rest of your life.
That's it.
Um,
anyway,
so formula one starts this Sunday in Australia and last year then,
but Mercedes Benz teams where the a was where the um,
Mercedes Benz team,
sorry,
was the team to beat.
And this year evidently the Ferrari's are uh,
are looking like they're going to be really strong and a,
I guess everybody's rooting for.
Who the fuck is the Australian driver there for?
The uh,
the red bull team.
He's coming down there.
What the fuck's his name?
What's his name?
Uh,
Daniel.
Ricardo.
Hello?
Yeah,
you're getting ready to leave.
Does she still remember who I am?
She was looking at me like,
who the hell is this guy?
All right sweetie.
Huh?
I get a smile.
Can I get us to staring at the microphone?
I liked that.
How are you going to get in show Biz treed may lago food.
Yeah.
I think she's kind of over me.
Let me hang with it for like two,
three hours today.
Get that bond back.
Get the bond back.
Yeah.
Can you say bye Bye Daddy?
She's just staring at it.
She'd read.
Look at a pillow then me.
Hey Buddy.
You remember me?
Look at me.
Who Do you think paid for that one?
Z.
That was me.
Nothing.
She's look looking down.
She's got no interest.
Unbelievable.
That's the kind of charisma half.
All right.
You guys go have fun.
I'll see you.
Bye everybody on the clock ass.
All right,
bye.
See you later to my two way.
Um,
all right.
So,
um,
she didn't look at me once.
Um,
whatever.
I understand.
Okay.
It's a brand new brain still working.
She's putting together her shit.
The way I'm putting together my act.
Either that or she already doesn't like me,
but you know,
I really can't blame them.
Um,
Daniel Ricardo is the guy,
but here's the thing about him.
Everybody in Australia claims that guy.
All right.
Which is bullshit I think because he didn't move to fucking Australia till he
was seven.
He came from Sicily.
All right.
I bet.
I bet he's got some stories about everybody teasing them with his fucking
accident when he first showed up to Australia,
but he's got some stories.
Any Sicilian,
so you know,
you know,
he never forgets,
but whatever.
Australia would like your claim him maybe you got kicked out like all those
bricks and sent to that fucking land.
Who knows?
But um,
so everybody's going to be pulling for him.
I can't fucking away.
I can't,
I can't believe how excited I am for this shit.
They finally stuck it through one of those whole seasons.
Now I'm totally into it,
so I'm probably borne a lot of you.
But um,
oh no.
Sorry.
Let's get to the,
let's get this old bull shit here.
Um,
did I already talk about everything?
Oh,
you know what else I did when I was up there?
Um,
the Improv up,
they have found a,
a,
a drum room for me.
And on two days I got to play for two hours,
both fucking days.
I snuck four I was in,
that's what I do when I'm on the road cause I can't really play drums,
you know,
as much as I like,
which is basically an hour to two hours every fucking day.
I can't do that anymore.
Now I get out,
you know,
a couple a couple of days a week if I'm lucky.
But I got the whole practice pad kit and all that shit here.
So,
um,
I got to go out and do that shit.
See how awful my playing is now.
It was really fucking depressing,
you know,
but it was still a good time.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Let's,
let's read.
Oh,
you know what?
I have announcements I have to do if I sound like I'm all over the place,
it's cause I got like two hours.
Fucking sleep flight was at like 6:50 AM you know,
I,
I never,
I usually don't do a podcast when I flew the same fucking day.
So.
All right.
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh,
I've got to remind the listeners about,
uh,
Deanna Adler's,
Steven Adler,
his mom.
Um,
I interviewed her with Steven Adler and um,
Jamie Adler,
um,
that was posted yesterday.
Please listen to it.
And um,
Steven's mother,
mother is going to be at Barnes and noble doing a book signing,
um,
a week from yesterday.
So that will be the 29th.
March 29th.
She's going to be there.
Let me,
but let me double check on them.
Make sure no,
fuck that up.
That would be a bad thing.
It would defeat the for purpose of them coming on here.
All right.
Where am I?
Um,
yeah,
the 29th at 7:00 PM at the growth on Fairfax here in Los Angeles.
Um,
she's going to be at the,
uh,
at the fucking,
at the God damn mall down there where they used to have two stadiums by the way.
These to have a football stadium down there and they used to have a baseball
stadium.
If you ever watched those old school black and white home run derbies and you
wonder where they are.
I always thought they were like in like the Washington Center to see original,
you know,
Washington senators ballpark.
But they were actually out here in la,
which makes sense because it's a fucking TV show.
Anyways,
now it's a CBS slot and we're all,
that shit stood,
you know,
they knocked it all down and then they did like 9 million episodes of the
prices.
Right.
So you know what the world moves ahead.
All right.
In don't Chai.
No,
sorry.
Just blew out your ear.
Drums.
Indochino everybody.
Geno talk about how um,
a made to measure suit fits compared to a generic off the rack suit and now
every man looks better in a suit.
Hey,
why don't you fucking write something and I'll,
I'll read that.
I got to sit here and riff.
You know,
they used to do that to comedians way back in the day.
They probably still do it.
We used to go on for commercial auditions and he'd show up and they,
you know,
there's no coffee,
there's no coffee.
They just want to see personality and then you go in there and you hold up the
product and you'd sit there and riff and all this shit and then they would just
steal all your jokes.
They wouldn't hire you.
And then they'd write the copy.
Oh,
I think I told this story.
Patrice fucking called them out on it.
That's right.
I think I told this actually recently too much and I'm standing there.
He goes,
he just walked in like a can of coke and just stared all like three of them
down.
Just so what?
What is this horse shit?
They all imploded and told them exactly what the fuck they were doing.
All right.
Do I really need the riff about this?
Okay.
Do you know?
Unless you're,
unless you're fucking the exact same measurements of a mannequin,
you know you're not,
something's gonna look fucked up.
He just not going to look right.
Okay.
If you have a suit that's fucking tailor made your body,
obviously you have a buy a top for your car.
You know,
if you buy the one for your model,
your model car,
it fits like a glove as opposed to just getting some generic one.
It's a little gust of wind and it blows right off.
Do you want you suit pants to come flying off and then you Dick's Pekin outta
your boxers at the Christmas party or do you want to fish soup?
Well,
thank God for Indo Chino.
Whatever the fuck they are,
they making it easy to get a perfectly tailored suit and an incredible price.
You could choose from hundreds of top quality fats.
Are there hundreds of fabrics?
How many are there?
It's like cotton silk and ray on in my world.
The fuck else is there?
Plastic leather.
Yeah,
that's it.
I thought there was less fabrics and it was fucking banks.
Um,
okay.
Not individual bags.
I mean like chase wells Fargo.
I the fucking me.
Hey Bill.
Why don't you just read the copy?
All right,
fucking relax.
All right.
You can choose from hundreds of top quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it,
whether it's for work,
a wedding,
okay.
Or another special occasion,
whether you're a defendant.
Yeah.
What are you running for office?
What are you coming to town?
Are you going to sell all the fucking rubes their instruments that don't exist?
Indochina has a suited up as suited up hundreds of thousands of men and are now
the largest made to measure men's wear brand in the world.
Here's how it works.
Visited show showroom or shop online and indochine o.com pick your fabric.
Choose your customizations from lapels to pleats to jacket linings in more.
Place your order and wait for it to arrive in just a few weeks.
This week my listeners can get any premium in Dope Chai.
Don't shoe for only 389 bucks.
Three and 80 I boxing is a sport coaches that come with pants.
I didn't do china.com when you had to burn at checkout,
that's 50 off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus shipping
is for free though to get a fucking,
you know,
a custom suit made to measure for only 389 bucks.
That's pretty fucking good.
How do you spell Indochina?
I N D O C H.
I n.
O.
I.
N.
D.
O Chi,
eno.com promo code birth for any premium suit for just $389 and free fucking
shipping.
All right.
How many more do we have of these fucking things?
The Black Tux,
everybody.
The black,
the black,
the black tops.
Everybody looking great for a wedding or a special event has never been easier
with the black tux.com with a high quality rental suits and Tuxedos delivered to
your doorstep.
The Black Tux is giving guys a new way to rent and get this,
get a lot of this everybody.
The black Tux offers free home.
Try on so you can see the fit.
I always pictured when you're trying it on some old guy standing on your front
porch looking through the screen door.
You know it was old man clothes and around his fucking,
you know with his tape measure around his neck.
I wouldn't fuck you.
Call it not a tape measure one to the tape measure for people whenever you call
that thing the best part,
it's completely done online.
No trips to the tuck shop required.
The black,
the black Tux like the Ohio state,
the Black tux.com lets you create your look or choose from tons of styles.
Selected outfits starting at just $95 these suits have a modern fit and are made
from a far from fine Italian wool.
All there's another fabric,
cotton silk leather,
Raytheon will five down 95 to go the highest quality on the rental market and if
you have any questions or issues,
their expert customer care team has your back every fucking step of the way and
after ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
That's a full two weeks to try it on and make sure everything fits.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
When your event's over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that to get $20 off your purchase?
Visit the Black tux.com/ [inaudible] that's the black tux.com/birth for $20 off
your purchase.
All right.
Hey,
I got to get a glass of water.
Hold on a second.
All right,
I'm back.
I apologize if he can hear construction in the background.
It's not,
it's not my house.
Thank fucking God.
It's the house next door.
But you know,
the houses are all so close together out here for whatever fucking reason.
Um,
probably gives us 7 billion people live out here.
I distilled genes.
Everybody great jeans.
Oh,
they don't have to be complicated.
I can't find the buttons.
If you're not into crazy stitching,
diamonds are embedded studs.
You're not alone.
Distilled,
pronounced,
distilled offers luxury grade denim at an affordable price.
Jeans that would normally cost you hundreds to still just has for fucking 75
bucks that utilize the same fabrics,
factories,
and wash houses as the best known brands and designers.
So the same fucking poor bastards are washing all these genes while skipping the
markups and the middlemen,
the result,
pure,
unadulterated denim without the rental runaround.
Just go to distill.com spelled DSTL l d.com and see where it minimalist design
meets maximum comfort.
Oh well these things feel great on your bulls.
They guarantee the fit.
They'll ship them to you for free and you can give free returns until you find
the perfect pair.
I,
they actually sent me a pair of these things.
A fucking great.
That's great.
And yet you don't have to go to the mall.
It's fucking wonderful.
Distilled has been featured in Forbes times and tech crunch as well as on denim
clad celebrities in Gq and vogue distilled is the only place the u s you can get
this quality of denim for this price point.
You can,
you can find their amazing selection of outerwear,
leather jackets,
tee shirts,
and more using the same principles of the high grade materials at low and costs.
Distilled is your answer.
To elevate your style,
just go to distill.com/bird right now to get 10% off your first pair.
D,
s t l d.com/.
Bar.
All right.
Legal Zone,
mercifully the last one.
MMM.
Oh Shit.
It's national small business month.
It always says@legalzoom.com.
You know something that national small business month is like when you have some
shithole store that always has that sign up,
but that they're going out of business going out of business and they were in
business for like another 10 years.
Um,
anyways,
national small business month that legals of.com is,
it's here and timing couldn't be better.
Approval rates for business loans are up.
Oh Great.
And so as computer consumer confidence,
but it takes a lot more than a good timing to launch a successful business.
That's why legal zoom created a free business startup kit.
Part of being an entrepreneur is utilizing the right resources to help you
succeed.
You can't be an expert at everything,
so go to legal,
so talk com slash startup today and download your free startup kit.
You'll get educated age,
educational ebooks and legal zoom discounts to save money,
setting up your business.
Plus you can save thousands of dollars Mucho Dinero through legal zooms
partners.
Um,
what?
Plus you can save thousands of dollars through legal zooms,
partner offers to help with financing,
marketing and day to day operations things you'll need to run a successful
business.
Did I write that sentence?
I could spend 20 minutes trying to break that fucking thing down.
Trying to figure is that a fragment?
Is that a run on?
There's no obligation aber everybody.
Just a lot of great resources.
Legal isn't a law firm.
Why would you think that?
Just because it says legal in their name,
but they're dedicated to make life easier for the business owners.
Whether you're thinking of starting a business already run one,
go to legalzoom.com/startup during national small business month to take
advantage of your free business startup kit.
That's legal.
zoom.com/startup oh guess what?
I wanted to thank somebody.
Somebody on Twitter sent me a,
somebody uploaded an entire Boston Bruins versus Chicago Black Hawks from 1974
and it's the Bruins feed.
So it's Fred Q sick doing the game.
Spoiler alert,
the Chicago Blackhawks win the face off.
They win the draw,
it goes back to stand Makita who shoots it down to the Bruins and,
and it's then picked up by Bobby your and it's,
it's the whole fucking game.
I just sat there and it's,
it's a great,
great quality.
I hope nobody goes into fucking takes it down.
It's unbelievable.
If you just want to check it out,
like,
um,
the first thing I always noticed decides from no helmets is like how small the
goalies are.
So you can,
one of these guys scored like a fucking everybody,
you scoring 50 goals,
but so many people scored 50 back then these guys barely took up.
Like it looks like a third of the net standup goalies.
You know,
they played goalie,
they look,
they look like they're in the rock cats.
So just fucking kick their legs out and shit.
But it's,
it's,
so,
um,
I'll,
you know,
I'll actually,
I'll maybe I'll put a link to it,
um,
from the podcast.
Podcasts are at the MMP.
Is that what the Twitter is?
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
anyways,
that's the,
uh,
that's the podcast here for this Thursday.
I got something I got to go do.
I apologize.
I know it was a little scatterbrained here,
but however you can listen to some nice music and then listen to a podcast,
um,
from,
I don't know when,
I don't know when it's going to be.
It's from,
from yesteryear.
When I was a little bit younger,
my brain wasn't as scattered.
Briana,
that's always been scatterbrained.
Who's getting to,
all right,
please enjoy the next half of the podcast and
have a nice weekend.
You'd cut
places with touches
things out,
back
bring out,
makes me
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
The Monday morning podcast for a March 25th,
fucking podcast is to start to feel like groundhog day for me.
Might be a little grumpy,
a little extra grumpy this week because,
uh,
I don't want what happened.
I,
uh,
well I do know what happened.
Um,
I went out drinking last night and I stayed out until about two in the morning
and,
uh,
I was driving home and I saw a coyote and I slowed down and for some reason felt
the need to yell at it in a,
just to see what it would do.
Because according to Black Comedians,
that's what white people do around wild animals and God damn.
And I am the stereotype
Parker Shi
[inaudible].
That's literally what the fuck I did.
I was a hacky def jam bit and those were two of the worst impressions of two
races you're ever going to hear.
Um,
but go fuck yourself.
I'm still in my pajamas.
He wear pajamas bill.
Um,
when it's cold in my apartment,
I do still comfortable with my sexuality.
Let me tell you something.
If you wear pajamas as a man and you don't have a child,
you're just,
you're a fucking,
I don't know what,
but you're not something,
I want to be around these Pajama bottoms or my way of saying that I hate my
shelf.
Oh,
Bill,
why would you say that?
Um,
anyways,
yeah.
So I just pulled over and I started
yelling at this coyote
and anyone has found that hey,
if they do something,
then I started whistling at them,
you know,
not in like a sexual way.
I'm not a creep.
I was whistling and I'm like,
it was domesticated.
I just want to see if I could fuck them up,
you know,
just can we
can we believe
and think was looking at me like,
dude,
are you serious?
And I was like,
no,
not really.
I just want to see what you would do.
You fucking cunt.
And I drove home and I had some Salami and some horseradish cheddar cheese.
And uh,
oh,
you know,
when I got the other day,
I got this new Sam Adams.
Um,
I really am a Douche bag this week and wearing pajamas.
I'm drinking Sam Adams.
And if I have a story that involves me having a sandwich with an olive in it,
you should really just unsubscribe to my podcast at this point.
Or maybe any story when I'm standing here in a blazer with a pipe.
Um,
yeah,
I bought this new Sam Adams Beer,
like uh,
you know they had like the seasonal ones.
What is it that the blackberry something beer.
I know it sounds gross,
right?
That's what I was thinking.
I'm like,
that sounds gross.
but a Sam Adams,
somehow they make this shit tastes good.
That Sherry Week Cherry wheat was something that bears,
I drank and I thought it was the most delicious beer I ever had.
And by the third one I felt like I had eaten the whole bag of candy and I was
like,
I need to stop.
But I still get those.
I like the somewhere else.
I figured fuck it.
You know what it was?
I had just seen a Sam Adams commercial and I fucking challenge you to not want
to go drink 12 beers after seeing a Sam Adams commercial.
You ever see those commercials?
And the guy sticks his fucking face and those hops
grabs two big handfuls.
They show how many extra hops they put in,
which I don't even know what that does.
Evidently it makes it more tasty.
And then when they put it in dead fucking dead beer,
glass shape,
shape,
like a voluptuous woman,
you know,
and it just looks that perfect color.
That's what was in my head.
And I was at the grocery store,
I was like,
Oh man,
they got a new flavor and that guy's face and the hops that's very sexual,
like he's got to use buried his face and some chick's pussy.
And then the end,
they show her all filled up and fulfilled,
you know,
all filled up and fulfill.
There's a sentence for you.
So anyway,
Black Berry,
sweeter the bass,
I'm led darker the berry,
the sweeter the juice they got me,
they all went sex on me and I fucking bought it.
And I would tell you that was the worst goddamn tasting beer I've ever had my
fucking life.
Okay.
You know,
I'm a big fan of these smaller brewers,
even though they're huge.
Sam Adams is huge now,
but I'll tell you the Sammy,
he missed the mark on that one cause that tasted like a,
I don't know where it tasted like
it tasted like Sam Adams armpit.
Okay.
That's,
that didn't even make sense under said this,
avoid the Sam Adams blackberry.
Whatever the fuck it's called.
It's like,
where the fuck was I thinking blackberry.
You don't what the advertisement should that for?
That shit should be,
it should be.
It's not a wine cooler.
It's not a beer.
Or maybe they get a bad cop buddy movie.
You know,
he's a bear.
He's a wine cooler and together they taste like ask what is the,
I'm actually my refrigerator right now.
The blackberry.
Ah,
Jesus.
I can't pronounce it with beer.
Is it from a fancy German way of spelling?
Uh,
whatever fucking word that's supposed to be.
That's not a word.
There's no space between it.
I didn't want the fuck that is
and yeah,
I feel like I'm in Woodstock right now.
You ever see that thing where they're like,
stay away from the red tabs,
man.
I'm telling you,
stay away from the Black Berry,
Sam Adams with bear.
All right?
It's not a good fucking scene.
And yes,
Jesus Christ.
What,
you know,
that's it.
I'm done with that.
I'm,
anytime there's any sort of fruit in a beer,
you gotta be done.
Although I do like what does that bear?
They put the slice of orange and the,
uh,
I'm just really going to just say one douche bag.
Think about my personality after another on this podcast.
This is what it is,
you know,
and for some reason,
one of you finds me to be your hero and you,
uh,
took out the CD cover and taped it on the ceiling above your bed.
And I just realized that all of a post or myself,
what kind of,
what kind of fucking entertainer or am I that I don't have that poster,
you know what I mean?
When I'm standing under the tree,
you know,
both hands up on the tree branch above me with the little seashell necklace and
my shirt opened down to my navel.
Then little Shaun Cassidy poster a,
that's when you know you made it.
That's when you know you made it.
When you're,
when you're posing for that picture and nobody around you is telling you it's a
bad idea,
that's when you know you made it.
That's when you know,
because you are making so much fucking money.
People are afraid to tell you that maybe you shouldn't be sitting on a tire
swing with one leg in the air,
you know,
for the poster of your upcoming tour.
Um,
okay.
That was a long way to go to do a Shaun Cassidy reference.
Um,
anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast and uh,
if you are new to my page of my website or on my myspace page,
um,
welcome.
I did one of these every single Monday and people send me a list of questions of
collections,
not questions,
questions,
because it is the internet.
Um,
they send me lists of questions and I tried to answer them to the best of my
ability.
It's fucking pajamas a killing me.
I'm fucking,
I with my brain.
I don't know.
I gotta let my brain this week,
Clinton,
my fucking brain,
what am I freak?
I'm freaking out about something right now and I can't even figure it out.
What the fuck it is.
Um,
but anyways,
I do this podcast every single week.
Yeah.
They send me questions,
questions,
and they,
uh,
send me their list of underrated overrated things.
They,
uh,
give me movie reviews.
They asked me for advice.
They tell me to go fuck myself every once in a while.
Someone such a constantly become douche bag of the week and a,
and lately people have been sending me stories about revenge.
Um,
which I find fascinating because that's one of the few evils that I've,
uh,
I've actually resisted.
I have not partaked in,
um,
Oh,
before I get too deep into this podcast.
And why let you guys know that my,
uh,
my standup special,
why do I do this?
Evidently is on demand.
So,
uh,
if you want to have a little party,
you know,
get out your little fucking not tea cups and a table that's way too big for you
to be sitting at because that's what you do.
At a tea party.
Don't yet.
Does anybody over the age of five have a fucking tea party?
Do they do that over in England or do they just have fucking tea and just sit
there and stare out of the clouds?
Um,
all right,
let's get on with the broadcast.
Okay.
That was my opening.
Just burst of energy trying to make this fucking thing funny because,
uh,
I only got five hours sleep last night.
Oh,
poor fucking baby.
You only got five hours sleep and now what are you gonna do with the lay around
the next day,
the rest of the day,
and you fucking pajamas.
You know what about me,
Eh,
the fucking work in man Trican boilermakers till six in the morning.
Now I'm operating heavy machinery.
Go Fuck Yourself.
It's not my fault.
Okay.
Fuck you.
You're doing heavy machinery that makes you make when like fucking 30 bucks an
hour,
30 bucks an hour to take that on mountain.
All right.
That made no sense.
What's so fucking ever,
um,
I just have a bunch of random notes here.
Notes that I've made over the past week.
Here's an idea.
I had in an airport,
nothing suffers like the luggage of fat people.
And I don't know how I came up with that.
I know what it was.
I just saw this woman dragging her wheelie sideways or was it a guy?
I can't remember.
Once you get to that size,
is it really matter if you think about that?
It's become so big.
You just come asexual.
This is my,
uh,
late night DJ voice sort of,
trying to convince you with some things.
Um,
all right.
And that was creepy.
I'm sorry.
All right.
What do you want to talk about?
Creepy.
Let's talk about how Obama,
President Obama,
oh,
uh,
Barack Obama was on the tonight show this week.
Did that disturb anyone as a fucking American?
Is he in dude,
where's my car part too?
You know,
what the fuck are you doing on the tonight show?
I got a big army,
my girlfriend about that and I said,
oh,
it's good.
It's a great way to reach people.
It's like when you have a fucking friends conference,
right.
I got to do is wheel out that podium.
The whole world sits around and watches it.
I couldn't,
I couldn't sit there and watch him.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
dude,
[inaudible] like near the red phone.
What if the red phone rings and you're on there,
you know,
picking your fucking march madness brackets.
It's unreal how the presidency of has just gone downhill just over the last
fucking 10 years.
Like right around 10 years ago was when Bill Clinton got impeached because of
some fucking Skank,
you know,
every president.
Can you too cute?
Can you even begin to understand not only the amount of world leaders that have
been in the Oval Office,
but the amount of fucking skanks
that have been in there that does the original playboy mansion.
All right,
guys have been in there getting blown
for centuries.
Women love power guys loved blow jobs.
Okay,
and you and you marry the two.
You get the fucking Oval Office that is ground zero for that shit.
And the guy got fucking impeached for it.
It's right there.
I thought that knocked down the presidency,
that the president with fucking secret service at his fingertips can't get a
fucking blow job.
Right?
He gets busted and,
and then you had a,
what's his face?
Uh,
uh,
Georgie [inaudible] whose dad evidently didn't teach them how to give a speech.
So we had to look at that fucking retard for the last eight years,
given a speech where he sounds like somebody given a book report who didn't read
the book.
You know what I mean?
Kind of.
Secondly in Ariana,
he had that shit and now we got this fuck head going on the tonight show.
You know,
like he's Ashton Kutcher.
I don't know.
I don't like it.
This is three,
three presidents in a row where I,
I don't like what they're doing.
You wear the blue suit,
you wear the fucking tie and uh,
you,
you should have an air about you that you,
and he just shouldn't be on the tonight show.
You know what I mean?
And then this night show pad is Ashton Kutcher it,
President Obama.
You know what?
I didn't even watch it.
I'm like literally criticizing.
I did something I didn't even watch.
You know,
I just couldn't sit there and watch that showing.
Yes,
he gets dragged to presidents are limos and I just didn't have the Hemi
[inaudible] here.
We doing donuts.
We do it very notes.
Um,
I dunno.
All right,
let's,
let's get on with the fuck.
I'm really,
really in an extra fucking shit mood right now.
You know,
it all started last night when I yelled at that coyote,
you know,
that's what I did.
I turned my back on nature and I,
she kind of freaked me out cause it was just a couple of blocks down my,
uh,
my street.
You know what I mean?
It's like kill of a sudden.
It's like a fucking will Smith movie playing out at three in the morning.
And uh,
I was kind of wondering like,
where the fuck that thing came from?
I know the Hollywood hills,
they're kind of off there in the distance,
but uh,
you know,
oh,
what a coyote seat roadrunners.
Huh?
Who watches cartoons?
I do,
but they never catch them.
What does that even fucking true?
You know what I mean?
Roll hunters.
Can Fly.
Right.
They just choose not to.
They'd read around that.
Read a run,
be the fucking martyr.
Make all the other birds feel guilty for taking the easy way out.
All right,
let's get on with the questions here because this podcast is in a cul de sac
right now.
I have driven down the street,
it says not a throughway and I continued down the fucking street and now I'm
just driving around in a fucking circle.
Okay.
Uh,
Bill,
I've been listening to your podcast since I watched you perform and because it's
nice to hear someone use the word cunt every five minutes.
You know,
a lot of people who have been giving me shit about that,
say I used the word cut too much and that they're starting to use it in everyday
life and their,
uh,
you know,
they're dropping it in weird times.
All right.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to try to take,
I'm going to try not to use the word console much.
Alright.
ECON.
Hey,
he did a cunt joke.
All right.
In addition is the rest of the rest of the question.
But,
um,
how do you feel about non Irish,
the way Non Irish people celebrate Saint Patrick's Day?
Quite frankly,
it pisses me off.
It's a day to celebrate the patron saint of Ireland,
not to get drunk.
I'm from Cleveland,
Ohio and here we have a big parade downtown.
It's so annoying seeing the drunks,
filling the streets.
People stereotype us as if we're the only culture that has a drink.
Once in a while.
I'm Irish American and I'm probably the only woman of Irish descent who has
never been drunk.
Really.
My family and I usually have a traditional meal of boiled potatoes,
carrots,
cabbage,
corn,
beef and Irish Soda Bread.
Now let me tell you something.
If ever there was a fucking reason to get drunk,
it's the kill,
the taste,
boiled potatoes,
carrots,
cabbage,
corn,
beef,
and you can just taste the hot water on the fucking over.
Boiled vegetables on.
Every nutrient is just taken out of them.
You wonder why as Irish people have such pasty fucking skin and no pigment of
the boil on the fucking nutrition out of the,
out of the,
out of the vegetables anyways.
Personally,
she says,
I think traditional Irish food sucks.
And it's mostly because they didn't cultivate much except for potatoes and
cabbage.
We ever think maybe they were too fucking drunk to get a cookbook,
you know?
But I do like Irish Soda Bread.
I remember you saying you don't go out drinking.
I don't,
I don't think I ever said that.
Is that a Typo?
Um,
but you,
but do you ever do anything and do you like Irish foods?
Um,
I to admit,
I really do like a corned beef sandwich and I really do like potatoes.
I do not like boiled potatoes.
Boiled potatoes are disgusting and you need at least half a stick of butter,
salt and pepper to just kill the taste of what you did to it.
You know what I mean?
I'm trying to think of anything that you should,
boy,
other than drinking water during a fucking catastrophe,
you know,
what do you boil rice?
All right.
And then would you boil,
I dunno,
but let me get back to the question.
How do I feel about people,
uh,
who celebrates St Faxing?
I don't go out on Saint Patrick's Day.
That's a,
a,
it's a very bad day to go drinking,
you know,
everybody out in their green plastic hats and they'd say,
hey,
they're good.
Iin alligator and a long neck goose.
Yeah,
it's,
it's very,
um,
uh,
it's,
you know,
it's like drinking on New Year's Eve,
and all the dumb concert out with their stupid little Horry outfits.
And is this the sound of the noisemakers weren't ear piercing enough?
You got them shrieking over them.
It's just a horrible time to go out.
And,
um,
I still have in us to the question,
how do I feel about non Irish people celebrating Saint Patrick's Day?
I really could give a shit.
I think it's a statement of,
uh,
I dunno how empty their lives are or how the herd just follows whatever the fuck
they supposed to do.
You know,
there's always like that one traditional guy and he's got to wear the Sculley
cap in the Irish sweater standing over in the corner,
cutting into a bar of soap with a knife.
You know that guy.
Um,
yeah I could give a,
I'm a,
I'm German Irish and I could give a shit about a Saint Patrick's day.
I don't know the story of the patron saint and um,
yeah,
I don't give a fuck.
I think in the,
in the,
when I was in my twenties I used to go out to pubs on Saint Patrick's Day.
Um,
and I used to do it because I would thought I could get laid that night cause I
look so Irish.
And then some girls that are like,
oh my God,
this is what the day is about.
Here's the Leprechaun right here.
Maybe I'll blow him.
That's the only reason why I went out.
I was desperately trying to be interesting.
But now I just,
I don't go out.
I don't go out on new years and I don't go out on Saint Patrick's Day.
I don't go out on flag day and he sorta day Earth Day I stay home.
Those are,
those are,
those are just douche bag days and what you want to do is whatever people are
doing is you,
you do it the next day,
like Valentine's Day.
Everyone brings their broad out to go fucking whatever,
right?
He can't get a reservation anywhere.
The fucking prices are jacked up through the roof.
This is what you'd do.
You'd go out on the 15th that's what you do and you tell you woman that that's
what you're doing because you're going to get a fucking table anywhere you want.
You're not going to get raped on the charges.
You probably actually be able to go to a better restaurant than you would have
on the night of the 14th and that's a great like,
you know,
you know Bronx tale,
the lock,
the door test.
That's a great way to see if you're with the cool girl or not.
If she'd let you take her out on the on on the 15th cause it really doesn't make
a fucking difference,
does it?
You know,
you're going to get to see if she is an independent thinker or if she's fucking
stuck in must see TV,
you know,
and it's going to drag you to the Macy Day fucking Thanksgiving parade one day.
Cause that's what you do.
Everybody else is doing it.
We have to do it,
honey.
It's not that I don't love you.
We're just going to get right there on the price.
You know,
you're trying to find a bargain on Valentine's Day.
Uh,
I want to be rude bitch.
But you're in the relationship too.
You're not paying for the fucking meal.
How does that work?
Exactly.
You know what?
Now I'm not even taking out.
We'll go ahead and cry.
Go ahead and cry.
It's not going to work.
This is all fucking fake because you know,
I just expose you for being selfish.
I like that.
Now that was great.
You like that and you liked that little little reflected there?
I always,
when the hypothetical arguments.
Okay,
Bill,
how would,
uh,
how would I go about getting a personalized autographed DVD set from you?
DVD set?
I didn't know where they were releasing them in a set.
Do I have a trilogy of Dvds like the Godfather?
Um,
how would you go about that?
Uh,
you'd come out to one of my shows if that's what you would do and you'd buy one,
and I'd stand there and I'd fucking sign it for you.
And I'd smile like a jackass is,
I waited the excruciating eight seconds that it takes for a digital camera to
click before the three flash bulbs go pump
some of those disposable cameras,
as bad as they were for the environment,
I imagine.
How great will those things say cheese collect?
And it was over.
Now they fucking got those digital cameras.
They're like,
okay,
Lan till today.
And then you sit in there waiting and waiting with that fucking smile plastered
on your face.
You know,
like that fucking newscasts or it goes to throw it to the other newscaster in
the field and then it doesn't go.
And then you just staring at the entire state that you're broadcasting to now
off to Mike,
out in Chelmsford.
Okay.
We seem to be having some tactical hook.
I'll pay.
That's what it's like getting your picture taken on fucking digital camera.
And then what's even better is when they accidentally hit video and then you're
standing there with a smile on your face.
Like
he started talking through your taste is a god,
hold a button down.
You got to haul the dob.
Now many times that's happened to me after my shows and they're like,
oh my God,
I had it on video.
And those are the times when I wish I didn't sell shit at the end of my shows.
You know,
I like meeting people after my shows.
I definitely liked doing that.
You know,
sometimes you feel like a fucking idiot,
you know,
especially when people come up to you and like,
I did.
It gives us Joe,
can you just say pesto and then we'll take the picture now?
No,
I can't.
Oh my God,
you're so grumpy.
Shut up.
Take the picture.
Um,
all right.
Anyways.
Uh,
he said,
I didn't want to let me go on with this guy.
He says,
I'm happy to pay for it and I have a downloaded copies paid for to my iPhone,
but I want an autograph one,
so let me know what I need to do to get one where I had to pay for it.
All right?
I'm kind of being a Douche or,
but like,
um,
you know,
people ask me for like autographed photos and Shit.
Like I'm Fonzie sometimes and they never,
they like expect me to pay the postage and all that type of shit and it's just
like,
I'm not doing that.
Okay.
All right.
I hang out at the end of my shows.
I take pictures,
I autograph,
do everything but kiss fucking babies.
All right?
I do this podcast every week.
I'm not going to get myself into a situation where I got to go to the post
office,
you know,
every fucking,
every other day.
All right.
With Manila envelopes.
I'm not doing that shit.
You know,
trying to think of something to write before assignment.
That's the hardest thing about giving an autograph.
Can you make it out to Susie?
And then I always write Susie and then I sign my name and I'm like,
then I try to think what to write and I'm like,
uh,
God bless a Susie.
What's going on?
Bill Burr?
Ah,
Shit.
All right.
Who complains about signing autographs?
You know what I do.
I do.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
okay,
let's go.
Let's get on with this.
I'm really sounded like a fucking window.
I get off complainant.
I liked the way I acted.
Like I would see someone asked me for a photograph every other day.
I was going to say every 20 minutes and I'm like,
they'll never believe that.
I'll say every other day.
That's not even true.
It's usually like once a month and it's usually somebody with a fatal disease
and I still don't send it to them cause that's the kind of guy I am.
Alright.
Also bill,
let me move on here.
You should really promote the protests.
Uh,
okay bill,
you should also,
you should really promote the podcast for download on iTunes.
That shit is so easy that once you do it,
you have the podcasts on your iPhone and you can listen to it in the car
anywhere other than in front of a computer.
Well,
there you go.
Everybody,
you can download it on iTunes.
Thank you sir.
He just hyped it for me.
All right.
Last week I had a big question about the differences between hotels and motels
and uh,
well first of all before we get into this shit,
um,
how about those Bruins?
Huh?
Beating the New Jersey devils.
I got any New Jersey Devil fans out,
dad,
you like that little four to one victory.
I'm just fucking with you.
You guys got a great team and if you're not watching hockey right now,
I really feel bad for you all you guys watching March madness and uh,
you know,
waiting for that,
that awful song at the end of the tournament,
when they show the great moments,
I had a tree,
they usually pick the Lakeland was syrupy song as they show all the dunks in
slow motion and the people being excited and then crying.
What is this song that they sing to night?
How I need you.
Oh,
the dark
telling you right now.
Play off.
Hockey's coming the flyers of playing great.
The rangers lost yesterday,
but they're coming on.
The capital's a fucking ridiculous.
The goddamn Devil's got an insane team as always.
I really hate,
I really hate the devil.
I just hate their,
uh,
I,
I hate the country style of hockey that they played throughout the 90s with the
left wing Loc and the trap defense.
I swear to God,
not disrespecting,
you know Marty Bro over there in the big record that he got,
but you know,
it's a little padded.
It's a little fucking pad it with the fucking trap defense.
I mean,
he spent half his career have to save the,
made with skating behind his next stop in the puck because they just would dump
it in because they'd clog up the neutral zone and you know what I mean?
And that was also during the clutch and grab era.
Jesus Christ,
I couldn't,
I go to squeezed out a couple of shout outs.
All right,
that's bullshit.
I just,
I just hated that period of hockey.
And when I think about that period of hockey,
I think about the New Jersey devils and I don't still to this day,
I don't understand why the NHL just didn't say that's an illegal defense,
you know what I mean?
It's like when will Chamberlain was fucking dunking on everybody.
You know,
they came up with rules to,
to keep it competitive because it's a fucking business.
You know,
the three second rule,
you can't have some guy just standing in the fucking paint who's nine feet tall.
Goaltending they came up with that shit and they came up with the legal
defenses.
I still don't know why they allow that defense.
It's the worst fuck they had to get rid of the red line because of that shit.
I don't know.
But I was watching yesterday and they don't play it anymore,
so I really enjoyed it.
But as usual,
they just got great fucking players and they play smart fucking hockey.
And uh,
I dunno,
I dunno.
It's going to be a tough fucking road and a,
for those of you who are,
who kind of want to know.
This is a question I have for you.
Who the fuck are these people who are trying to get the fighting out of hockey?
I don't understand them.
You know,
watch a different sport.
Hockey is not for you.
All right?
And if it's somebody in hockey stopped doing it,
don't get rid of fighting and hockey.
All right,
and think that you're going to be as popular as baseball,
basketball or football.
You're not all right.
You're a rogue fucking sport.
You are really in hard about hockey.
If you never,
if you didn't grow up playing it are in like a hockey family or in a hockey
town,
it's duck the hardest fucking game to watch on TV.
I was kind of noticing that yesterday.
Like you literally have to be not only watching what's on the screen,
but what is like literally 20 feet to the left of your screen.
You know what I mean?
You got to,
you got to figure out like a guests when they're like,
you can have a while.
You watch it long enough,
you know what's going on to the left or to the right of the play.
That is literally off the TV screen.
He just called the change in lines.
Like you just know shit like that.
I can't see the puck.
Well fucking watch bowling.
You're blind bastard.
All right.
It was a question I had last week.
Someone I asked,
what's the difference between a hotel in a motel?
You know what I mean?
And I thought it was basically,
you know,
if your door opens up out to the parking lot,
that is a fucking motel.
It's a serial killer.
Doesn't have to kill somebody at a front desk and get an an elevator or at least
walk a hundred yards of carpet before he kills you.
That is a hotel now that is a motel.
I'm sorry if he has to do that shit.
That is a hotel.
And evidently I am right.
Because one person said that I was,
and that's the amount of research that I do with everything in my life.
Well,
if you drive up to your room,
uh,
you are at a motel and use it as a,
and you deserve to hear the people fucking next to you.
Oh wait,
I read that wrong because I have dyslexia.
Let me start over again.
Take a deep breath focus.
You can do this bill.
If you drive up to your room,
you are at a motel and you deserve to hear the fucking people next to you talk
about their free fucking Hbo.
Okay,
that was really funny and I butchered it.
Um,
anyways,
he goes a,
that shit sucks also.
You're killing me.
You're fucking killing me.
You spend $89 on a cheap motel.
Are you fucking nuts?
I always hear about this internet stuff and I never do it.
And he writes in capital letters.
Then he goes back to regular typing.
Listen to me,
go to Priceline.
Next time you're traveling and look up a hotel and pick the highest star rating
and do not bid any more than 89 bucks and you'll get the best hotel in the city
for that price.
I would tell you to go down to 59 or 69 bucks,
but just stick with 89 bucks.
Please just try it once.
I traveled the road for 14 years and I kicked myself in the ass when I realized
what I'd been missing out on.
Thanks for the free podcast to the highlight of my Monday mornings.
Well thanks for the fucking Info.
That's that William Shatner.
Shit.
I never even,
I don't even pay attention to commercials.
I just look at the fucking,
the glitzy lights.
I'm like,
Oh wow,
look,
I will shit.
And William Shatner,
you know,
he's keeping it going.
Did Star Trek 40 fucking years ago and he's still working,
you know.
Um,
and he has a hell of it to pick.
All right,
Asheville,
here we go.
Here's the Asheville,
a section of the podcast that I just started there.
I was all right,
ask bill.
Bill,
I need your advice.
I had something very horrible happened to me and Oh man,
this is brutal.
Settle into your fucking your staples office chair for this one.
People.
This is,
this is a tough situation.
All right.
And I dunno if I got the uh,
life experience to get you out of this one.
Um,
Asbell okay,
bill,
I need your advice.
I had something very,
very horrible happened to me and it's nobody's fault but mine.
Nobody's fault but mine,
Ben in and Nnn,
sorry,
let's up.
All right.
I have this,
I have this friend
who don't get me wrong is a good friend,
but is that one type of friend who's really fucking annoying but wanting to hang
out 24,
seven.
Just recently I got a new girlfriend and I've been spending all my time with
her.
My friend then became jealous,
becoming more and more knowing by making me feel bad for being with my girl.
Anyway,
long story short to vent,
I wrote an email to my girl just trashing my friend up and down the fucking road
for being the moron.
Wait a minute.
Could you use a smaller type set?
You know,
I suck at reading a bulk IC,
trashing my friend up and down,
but being the moron that I am,
and here we go,
people instead of just sending it,
emailing it to her,
I checked this,
send all options,
sending this horrendous email to everyone on my email list.
Oops.
My email list doesn't really have too many people on it,
but it does have the friend I was trashing.
Of course,
it just made,
it just made me realize that you shouldn't say things behind someone's back if
he can't say it to their face.
So I'm nominating myself for Douche bag of the week.
Lol.
What would be your advice?
Send an apology email or just ignore them.
Ah,
that's the worst.
That's the worst.
Because you know what sucks about that is
you,
you're 100% in the right that this guy is a douche bag,
but now you became the Douche bag because,
uh,
and you know what's funny is if he had a girlfriend,
he would be doing the same thing.
He just wouldn't have been a
dumb enough to fucking send,
hit send to everyone.
Uh,
I dunno,
what should you do?
Should you send an apology email?
No.
First of all,
stop writing things down on paper.
That's number one.
Don't ever do that.
And number two,
learn how to spell apology.
There's no e
I wouldn't just ignore him.
You got to take it like a man.
He just got to walk up to him and just be like,
yeah,
you know,
I wrote it.
And you know what I meant that you've been a con and a and that's it.
So you want to punch me in the face knowing that I'm going to defend myself and
punch you too.
So,
you know,
that's kind of where we're at.
I know which shocks,
I dunno.
You know what I think,
uh,
I'm getting uncomfortable thinking about the situation you put yourself in.
I really don't know what to tell you.
I don't know what to do with that one.
Uh,
you got caught and you fucking,
you kind of turn yourself in.
You should be on America's dumbest shit.
Talkers,
yellows,
you know,
you know that show,
right?
Americans,
dumbest criminals.
And the guys put whip cream on their face and they stand in line at the bank and
it melts off their face and by the time they get up,
this is what this guy,
he did the email equivalent of that.
I don't know what you got to do.
I would just,
I have the laugh.
I have no idea.
You know what?
I got no advice on this one.
I got,
I got to smell this to listeners.
All right.
I got to go to way.
Uh,
what did they say that you got to,
I got a phone,
a friend here.
If anybody has any advices what to what the fuck this guy's supposed to do?
Um,
I'll read it next week because I don't know what to do.
You've,
you've uh,
it's checkmate.
Checkmate.
Uh,
I don't know what to do.
Dump your girlfriend,
change your name and moved to Alaska.
Um,
either that or he had just,
uh,
I think he just got to take it.
I think he just got to take Eric.
So when did you learn no more fucking emails.
Right.
And you've got to watch out too,
cause you eventually you fucking girlfriends.
And even,
even when she's in a good mood,
she's still going to tell half the fucking story to uh,
to one of her close friends.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno why they just stay.
They really,
um,
I don't really think women know bad at keeping it.
He didn't guys are overrated,
but their ability to keep a secret.
I'm going to keep it a secret because I forget shit
cause I'm,
I have any sort of code.
I just,
you know,
I have really bad memory and after like three days,
I can't remember.
Like you could literally be like,
Bill,
anyone don't say anything but I fucked so and so's wife.
I feel like shit,
I can't believe it.
I have so much guilt.
I just had to tell somebody,
please don't tell anybody.
And I'd be like,
yeah,
okay.
Yeah Dude,
no problem.
The problem.
And literally,
I'm not saying two,
three days later,
but
by a year and a half,
if I went out to dinner with all the people involved,
maybe sometime around dessert,
I would be like,
oh,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
He fucked that guy is who I am.
That's right.
So it's not like I can keep a secret.
I just,
I can't fucking remember.
Yeah,
though.
We got it.
And then we understood what the example,
you don't need to go back into it.
Why don't you wrap up the fucking podcast.
All right.
You're 40 fucking minutes in.
I'll
relax.
It's going to be a long podcast,
but I don't get going here.
Um,
all right,
let's get on of revenge stories.
Okay.
This is a question I have because every revenge story seems to be from guys.
None of them seem to be from females.
So finally a woman chimed in with some sort of revenge,
but it wasn't really revenge.
Um,
or maybe it was revenge and she was just doing the typical thing that women do
when they tell stories as they never get to the fucking point.
No kidding.
Oh,
Jesus.
I'm crabby today.
All right.
Here is one from a hormone bill.
I usually don't take serious advantage on someone,
but I do take,
I take so much pleasure in other persons fuck ups and misery.
I always take comfort finding out that someone I hate has such a miserable life.
Here's a story about my egg head Douche ex boyfriend.
All right.
I already liked the sound of this.
To start to start the story,
I will admit that I was a cunt who ran rarely gave him any sexual,
anything sexual for two years.
Jesus Christ.
That's one of those relationships that died the final two years and no one,
no one just had the nerve to be like,
hey,
so why don't we both just fuck off anyways.
Uh,
she goes at least,
uh,
he put up with,
with that shit.
Any other guy would probably want to do stuff or get sick of it and dump my ass
anyway.
He always played a PC games such as world of Warcraft.
He got so fucking engrossed in that game and paying money every month to renew a
subscription.
What a dumb ass.
However,
plays can talk to other players in their guild or on their side of the,
of the game.
After I broke up with them,
I found out that he was talking to some chick behind my back for a year.
The story gets better.
Um,
this is,
uh,
this is where my revenge happens.
I don't have to do shit to ruin his life.
I didn't have to do shit to ruin his life.
Okay?
So after I'd dump his ass,
he continues talking to the [inaudible] from the game.
He thinks he's in love with her parentheses,
retard.
So he goes to Canada to be with her where she lives.
I guess he thought she was going to be the one and he proposed.
But a month later he gets deported back to America and like a dumb ass.
He lets her keep the $3,000 ringer and her finger after a short period of time.
He tried to go back but he gets deported again.
So he's a college dropout who lives at home with his mommy and he's out three
grand in addition,
while after he starts dating.
Oh,
in addition a while after he starts dating this Jewish bitch,
they were dating for about a year and a half,
one and a half years.
Then she dumps him because she decides it doesn't,
it's not going to work out cause he's Catholic.
And the icing on the cake is that all I have to do to make them feel even more
pathetic is let them find out.
I Bang my boyfriend
and everything he does usually comes back to me because he keeps in contact with
one of my good friends.
Anyway.
Anyone who was on my bad side who has fucked with me has always had something
come back to bite them in the ass.
I take great pleasure in that Jesus Christ.
Wow.
That is a fucking,
yeah.
Hell hath no fury.
I love how you dumped him and you think he's a loser and you're still getting
enjoyment that he has this horrific life.
That's scary,
man.
You know,
I usually expect that sort of evilness out of guys,
you know,
and just really frightening like that's,
that's a mom.
That's going to be somebody's mom.
Now My,
our why our hanger,
all right,
Bill is another story of revenge.
Um,
you know what?
There was what that story could think.
I'm being a jerk to that person.
It's that the guy really didn't do anything to you,
you know,
and he was a lame dude.
He was a loser.
You had dumped him and then his life continued to go down the toilet
and I know,
and you're just enjoying him getting dizzy as he goes down and I don't fucking
get,
anyways.
Anyways,
here we go.
Here we go,
Brent.
Story number two,
about 20 years ago I was living in downtown Chicago by the way.
This person is like,
I know I read really bad out loud,
but this guy is typing,
eat,
and even a smaller type.
I don't understand.
Can you guys type a little bit bigger and don't be a con and just give me the
biggest size.
Okay.
That's really a second grade joke.
All right.
We're trying to do something serious here.
People do whatever you want.
I don't give a fuck and I'll sit here and start it through the emails bill.
Okay.
Let me get out my magnifying glass.
About 20 years ago I was living in downtown Chicago and a high rise that had a
multilevel parking garage.
I paid a monthly fee and had a designated covered spot.
Skye was doing great.
It sounded like you worked like one of those.
Fuck Oh 20 years ago.
I think he was selling health insurance.
Um,
anyways,
one night I came home to find another car parked in my assigned spot and sense
it was about 2:00 AM I just said fuck it.
You know,
and drove to the roof deck where there was always plenty of open spaces and
about 10:00 AM I was looking out the window of my apartment and I saw a tow
truck driving down Lasalle Street with my car attached to the back.
Since I was on the 18th floor,
there was no chance to catch the tow trucks,
so I went down to the office and ask the manager management why my car was
towed.
She said that I was parked in someone else's spot.
I explained that someone was parked in my spot and that there was probably 30
empty spots on the roof deck.
Plus the fact that my car had a sticker on the windshield showed that I was a
resident.
She said that there was nothing she could do and I asked,
so I asked to speak to the person who had my car towed.
She called the girl who had my car towed and she came down to the office.
She was a total content about the whole situation in the assisted that she did
the right thing.
Well,
since I couldn't blast this cunt in the face,
I decided to take revenge on her car since I knew exactly where she parked.
Once again,
revenge is coming back to fucking up somebody's car.
All right,
so here we go.
Here is the revenge.
I waited about two months and then I got a syringe from my mother who was a
diabetic.
Did you make sure she had an extra one lb?
Didn't take her last one.
See,
see what happens when you go down the road of revenge.
Next thing you know,
you stealing syringes from your mom.
So anyways,
I still the syringe from my mom who's a diabetic.
Uh,
then I went to a sporting good store and bought [inaudible],
which is basically deer urine.
I then proceed to load the syringe with Rut and I injected in it.
I injected it into all the rubber moldings around the windows of this girl's
cars.
It smelled awful.
My parking spot was one level below or spot and I could smell it every day.
I know that taking revenge on a car is a wimpy move,
but it did feel good.
Always remember,
revenge is a dish best served cold.
Jesus Christ.
Wow Man,
you went like fucking CIA on that.
That's like something they would miss him like the autopsy cause it's little
fucking needle fucking holes.
Um,
I got to admit that that is definitely a,
I mean fucking up.
Somebody's car's not too original butter.
That is uh,
that dude you grew up in the backwoods.
No city kid knows about Rut.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You grew up in the backwoods.
You did,
didn't you?
You mom's a diabetic,
you know,
living in a trailer,
ate off of George Foreman Grill.
You're going to show everybody in your high school class that you were better
than this.
She got some big fancy job.
You lived in a high rise.
You had your own spot,
you know,
and you will looking out your window,
looking out over the south street's stroke and your cock,
and you thought you had the whole world by the balls.
And what happened?
They told you fucking Mazda Miata right out of your God damn spot.
Right in a brought,
you're right back to your childhood,
didn't it?
And then you took revenge the same way those kids took revenge on you in second
grade.
I don't want to fuck him going with this shit.
All right,
let's,
let's go to this next one.
Uh,
all right,
Bill.
Uh,
it's just another story of revenge bell.
So I did it check for two years on and off,
and this is my first real girlfriend in high school and I thought she was the
perfect,
most amazing girl in the world.
I was an idiot and like 17 old,
I'm still an idiot,
23,
but I sure as hell won't let this crap happen again.
Anyways,
I let her walk all over me and I just took it like a bitch.
It was the kind of thing where she could fucking cheat on me in front of me.
And I believe her.
If she told me she wasn't,
I was,
I was that fucking pathetic.
Eventually though,
after hearing that your girlfriend is cheating on you for so long,
it eats away at you.
Can you hear the foreboding music in the background?
Eventually she posted some bullshit poem on my space,
on my space.
About some dude she was going out with at the same time she was going out with
me.
Wow.
That's pretty bold.
And anyway,
she goes,
the Fucker,
uh,
who she was cheating with even had the balls to post on there talking about how
sweet she was.
So finally I had my proof.
She wasn't getting out of this and here comes the revenge till I actually
messaged the guy and start telling him that I'd been fucking her the whole time
that he's been going out with her.
He starts telling me that he even knows of her cheating on him and he took her
back.
So we teamed up to destroyer.
See,
see,
this is,
this is where it goes wrong.
This is where it gets evil.
This is why I do not partake.
They're teaming up now to destroy another thing and this is how it plays out.
All right,
here we go.
By this time I was out of high school and they were both,
and uh,
wait a minute,
but this time I was out of high school and they were both at the same high
school.
I guess the guy.
And this girl basically I showed up to her school and what we did was bring up
all this shit that she did up in the middle of all her little fucking friends.
She cared about so much.
She cares so much about and explained how much of a horse she was.
Other dues even came up and said they were going out with her at the same time.
I was fucking her and shit.
This bitch was the fucking public bicycle.
Everyone was riding with a completely ruined the rest of high school for now.
Five or six years later,
me and the dude are still friends because a wind,
there's a wind for the guys who got treated like shit out there.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
I guess it would have just fucking,
I dunno man.
I cut my losses,
cut my losses.
That reminds me of an of an intervention story where there was this girl whose
dad didn't stick around.
So,
uh,
she,
I dunno what,
and she developed young and,
uh,
the guys be like,
Hey,
let me see a titties.
And she just showed them to him,
not realize she just liked the fucking male attention.
So she's dancing as a cheerleader and I gotta I dunno what she did.
She blew a couple of guys.
And so she's dancing as a cheerleader and the hope her,
her entire college,
I mean,
high school class just started chanting whore,
whore,
whore or something like that.
And then she burst into tears and then she became a fucking alcoholic.
You know what I'm saying?
But you know something,
you don't,
you don't have the mentality to know that at that age and I show wasn't on.
So why am I playing armchair quarterback and ruining your event?
I Dunno.
Revenge.
Ya Know,
Maya,
I don't know.
Fucking creepy man.
We ruined the rest of high school for and then we high fived and kicked a puppy.
All right,
here we go.
Overrated.
Underrated.
This is the last thing here.
Um,
overrated and this is something that I've been meaning to bring up.
This is one of the eye overrated that I agree with.
I think the most overrated multi-blade raisers.
A few months ago,
I started using my dad's old double h double edged razor made almost 20 years
ago before I was born.
Born.
It's fucking great.
My face feels better than ever and I can get a hundred blades for less than what
it costs for an eight pack of those three or five blade cartridges.
Um,
if you got to shave like a man and introduce an element of danger to it.
I actually have a couple of straight razors too,
but it's too much work and I don't use them on a regular basis though.
There's nothing.
Sure.
Those fucking,
one of the worst things that ever happened me on the road was I left my
toiletries behind I think in Tampa a long time ago.
Not only did I use lose my little tough crowd,
uh,
a shaving kit bag,
I lost that fucking thing.
Um,
and I,
I lost my twin twin blade razor and then I went onto the triple red blazer and I
have a whisker underneath my nose that it just can't get,
it just doesn't get it.
It sucks around your Chin itch.
It's terrible.
The two blade razor is the shit and you will never get a closer shave than that.
Everything else is fucking bullshit.
I was wondering though,
what about the,
you've seen those things on TV?
We can sharpen your razor blades.
Anybody.
I mean,
anybody buy one of those?
Huh?
Is this podcast going on?
Well,
my God.
53 more minutes.
I gotta get Outta here.
Alright.
Underrated.
Uh,
your podcast.
It's fucking great.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
Uh,
here's another good one.
Overrated.
Chickson bars and clubs,
underrated chicks at the laundromat.
The skill set in these two groups is so far off.
It's ridiculous.
Chickson bars and clubs just spackle on so much makeup that they can barely hold
their heads up long enough to accept your drink before they shoot you down.
But Dude,
dramatic pause raising my eyebrows type shit.
Um,
he actually typed up,
um,
helping me with my reading ability.
I liked that.
I liked direction,
but dude,
a chicken,
the laundromat is so sexy.
It's crazy.
They're wearing probably the last clean shit that they own.
That's just a little too tight.
They don't,
they don't put on makeup.
So dude,
you're really sounding like a pervert right now.
You how they were in that last piece of clean closet they got,
yeah,
that's one of the two tight
down,
put any makeup on and then they're pretty at that moment and they look
unbelievable.
And you know,
you don't like to have for the rest of the time and just reading the rest of
your shit like a pervert.
Actually.
Dude,
you're actually,
you're right.
He makes some great points there.
Plus they're doing some responsible while they're hung over and they're trying
not to throw up when they're newly clean clothes.
Sorry,
I went too long.
He had dude,
you did.
You actually make a great point.
You do.
Yeah,
you did.
All right.
That's the end of the podcast.
Okay.
Kind of petered out.
Kind of like the Colorado River,
not reaching the ocean anymore.
Um,
anyways,
before I'm going to be in Saint Louis this week at the house of comedy,
um,
I have the link right there on my website.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com B U R r.com.
And I want to thank everybody who came out to my Monday shows at the punchline
in San Francisco.
I really wish I talked about that in the beginning.
Um,
being honest with you,
those were two of the best shows I've ever had in my life.
Um,
that second show,
it was ridiculous.
Um,
for those of you who weren't there,
I just started telling stories and uh,
I probably did close to an hour and a half,
15 minutes of which was actually from my act.
So,
uh,
you know,
it was all material I'm never going to do again because it was all family
stories and fucked up shit that I would never talk about on TV.
So,
um,
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
I had a great time and I'm thinking about coming up there again in a couple of
months at the punchline and maybe having that be a regular thing,
just coming up on Mondays and do one,
a couple of shows and just venting about the people in my life,
you know,
and I'm not having to worry about them ever hearing about it.
All right.
And,
uh,
that is it.
Thank you for listening to the podcast.
Thank you guys for contributing.
And,
uh,
what else?
Oh,
well,
you know what,
I,
people have been asking me about my myspace page,
asks him about the comments.
Um,
I kinda haven't been adding accepting comments since last September.
I just kind of forgot about it.
I just was adding friends and answering emails that you get.
The podcast took up a lot of times.
So I'm back to accepting comments.
I literally had like 400 or 600 comments.
It didn't allow me to,
uh,
you know,
here it is.
Comment approvals.
I'll click on this right now.
This is,
this is garbage time right now.
You don't even need to listen to this shit.
I have a 419 then I have to approve a,
so I'm trying to,
uh,
trying to get back on that shit.
But anyway,
that's it.
Thank you guys for listening to a podcast and I'm going to try to get some new
photos up there on my website and the myspace page.
You guys have a great week.
[inaudible].